hello and welcome to this video Skynet
one to eight
Skynet that aside from the Terminator
movies right let's go go go
Knight bTW - okay now before now is the
most critical move after which d5 is
very sharp
that is what I'm recommended in my BOGO
book but I don't remember that anymore
it's too long it's been too long so I'm
playing a more conservative way this is
not too bad the sixth set has been
played I think even by Magnus at some
point before that's a very
straightforward way of playing let's see
him it's probably useful to have the
straight in and now yeah how do I go
about that
knight c6 maybe I need to get a Ted of
counter play I can't even go 5 here now
that I see it what or d5 now as before
is hanging interesting yeah I think that
makes a bit of sense now to go d5 year
also with the Carina on a1 putting a
pawn to d5 is probably the right
decision it makes the bishop and queen
look a little bit silly against the d4
pawn yeah it seems okay if he goes a
five the question is if I should go to
d7 or 24 I think I'd tend to go to e4 it
just makes my take sir
that I did not expect really I can take
on b4 here
but this is just good right well what is
White's move now see takes looks odd why
would he give me that diagonal he had
this 100 K and now definitely 94 yeah
okay so I can take on D to that that
would be nice
already it's already a pretty good a
good position it's there's something
else then how would you continue than f6
so Bishop f5 also looks like a good
decision but he can go Bishop b3 that is
not entirely terrible maybe Queen d7
that interesting it's interesting
or just bishop g6 if he goes I mean this
is a useful move and he goes bishop and
maybe he will just play Bishop e2 hey
Bishop d3 is quite ambitious
okay let's it's rather slow okay I'll
take it and now just develop here on
97's actually it's actually threatening
Queen a8 in this position Queen a8 has
to go Bishop b2 and then Bishop b4 is
going to be strong
it cannot cancel now you cannot cancel
that's a big problem and Queen takes 8
he cannot play and I if he moves
something like you know quincy 1 or so
after we've got queen a5 this is not
easy for white I'm also just threatening
now to take on a1 playbook aah this is
actually the the most substantial threat
you know don't even know what he's
supposed to play now hmm you know not a
move you are happy about so taking it
okay if I go rook a to he will play King
c1
Bishop III takes it look a one check
wins the exchange okay I can take on the
tumor that was that was stronger even so
anyway it doesn't matter now I'm winning
the house here
you know just do this lose everything
yeah I think he made one or two really
questionable decisions this is probably
fine now before is still a fine move
there are some games you hear in the
database okay a five looks completely
normal now I think the five is correct
but he should definitely not take on d5
I think this is strategic error he
should go a five that's basically the
only move to consider it doesn't make
sense to take on d5 because my bishop
gets alive
and that is the most problematic thing
about my position that the bishop is not
doing anything on c8 I expected him to
play this and now I wasn't entirely sure
but the engine points out that c5 and
the only c5 is fine
that's probably probably true Liam c5
and him
I thought I can take at least and be
happy that I've traded something and
again these don't look all that
fantastic the engine considers this and
Bishop d7 yeah this is an interesting
idea I'm like trying to trade this not
sure if you manage that but yeah it's
tough to say I think the engine gives
why the slight advantage which is
probably fair it's got much more space
but I have some ideas b6f six and so on
it just like those are not positioned
all that well if the queen is on d1 in
such a position Bishop only three and
you can f4 and so on the White has a
couple of this is misplaced I mean okay
after C takes he takes I'm definitely
okay with the bishop just out and him
yeah it's not not easy b5 was played I
played Bishop a5 Bishop before it's more
powerful okay yeah I thought about it
but I wasn't and it is probably really
stronger just that I what I did not
really was aware office I was thinking
about this in a much too simplistic way
I was just thinking okay I'm not
threatening really to take twice only to
okay the king is in the middle of the
board but this is not really an issue
like if he does this for example this is
not so great the king is not ideal but
I'm not getting a big attack quickly and
engine kind of agrees to likes black but
I mean this is not winning or anything
but it is just yeah the computer says c5
here or Queen to e7 and moves like those
of course strong or keeping the tension
and then you can still do this and you
have the pin which is in itself very
annoying so this is better than Bishop
f5 Bishop e3
yeah just 97 must be fine c5 yes but
ninety-seven is a fun okay I took first
and then 97 it should be true ever
should be true I think after that it's
probably over you have to take on his
heaven or queen c-32 Queen eight it's I
think it's gone it's too it's too much
you cannot cannot defend it anymore
I have Queen a5 next after criminals for
example a Quincy one I go Queen eight
five and you're just in there pin and
you that you can you cannot get out
something like C five will break open
the see fraud that that is too bad I can
be one this just lose the house King c1
I can just take it's funny that the
engine doesn't even want to do the head
tonight p6 but yeah and this is not
winning everything
yeah he made two mistakes basically the
the this is this is one and then later
Jewish Bishop a three and an hour
Queenie raid and this is a strategic
strategy
sorry strategically interesting mistake
when you really should not help me solve
my problem peace okay thanks a lot for
watching